a few months later i was diagnosed with
breast cancer so it kind of put
everything on hold but at the same time
it gave me the kind of the kick to think
right i really need to go for this
so i went along and i did the dfe in
between
kind of my treatment i remember that was
yeah
crazy time so i had my operation in may
and then i went to mexico for treatment
towards the end of the year
but without your support and your
youtube videos and your
energy like even when i was in hospital
i was i just thought oh my god i feel
really awful and i literally just got
one of your videos and your voice and
your energy
just lifted my spirits hey what's up my
name's samuel leeds right now
i am in blackpool i'm in one of the best
streets in blackpool
but right there is one of the worst
houses
in the best street that was recently
purchased by one of my students
andrea harva how are you doing andrea
hey hi
so andrea this is not your first
investment you bought a lot of houses
before yeah but this is my only one in
blackpool
so why would you come all the way from
buckinghamshire which is where you live
and invest so far away in blackpool
which has got a little bit of a bad rep
why would you do that
because the yields are so high compared
to where i live in the southeast
yeah so you get so much more for your
money here
and yeah and it's just working really
well and tell me what's the advantage of
buying
the worst house in the best street
what's the rationale behind that well
because it's a really decent street and
i can make it
look like the rest of the houses
eventually which is currently under
construction at the moment we're having
it all re-rendered
and yeah and hopefully soon in the next
few months it will look
like the others so and it's going to
push the value up right yeah how much do
you pay for it
185 so she bought this house for 185
000 pounds let's go have a look around
on the inside i want to quench the
numbers
i want to work out how you put your team
together you you've got
what have you done with this you've
turned it into seven flats one night
it's already seven flats
um and we've just done a refurbishment
on one of the flats
um and then someone will be moving in
next week so let's go and have a look
around
so all the other flats are currently
talented um
except for this one so the tenants could
be moving in next week so this one we
had to refurbish
um it had a really low energy rating so
all the
ceilings had to be insulated and
everything all these walls was like
thick cream cheese plaster sounds awful
so they were all plastered um and well
it looks nice now let's go
to the uh to the kitchen
wow you must be happy i am because the
old kitchen was literally falling to
pieces wasn't it
and it was um it was it was a galley
kitchen so it was very small and narrow
and then we just made it all into one
room so okay
so this apartment yeah i mean this is a
really
nice kitchen yeah you could wet this out
it's so close to the seaside presumably
you could rent this out
a serviced accommodation we were gonna
um but obviously
during obviously the pandemic and
everything we decided to change it
and just have it as a a tenant moving
because we found a really good tenant
that was
you wanted to move in that was a friend
of um
someone in flat 2. that's the power
though
and i know you know a lot about this of
having exit strategies
yeah so you think you could work on this
yeah could work for that
great so how much rent is are they gonna
be paying in here so it's gonna be 650 a
month on this one
yeah um and obviously service
accommodation we would have made more
money but now our plan is to look for
something else around here
that we can run a service accommodation
because i know that the tenant who's
moving in here
will probably stay a long time won't she
because she's got a disabled son
yeah um you know she's a nurse um
and yeah she likes the flat and this
area as well
i know i said you bought the worst house
in the best street is this a decent area
it is yeah it's obviously when you get
closer to this town
center it's not as desirable that's the
crazy thing about blood
yeah the closer you get to the center
the more rough it gets whereas this is a
bit further out
yeah but they still work really well and
um property
yeah the seven flats six of them are
rented yeah
this one's gonna be ready next week
what's the total rent that you're trying
um it'll be 3050 a month
okay so so you're obviously not going to
manage this yourself
no it's important to have a good team
yeah and you have the fabulous
liam richard so i mean
these guys by the way these guys are
just great i've really
i've been in there i've been in their
house today yeah
lee's kitchen eating pot noodle we have
what do you think of this place
i love it i think it's great uh
it wasn't and it's been it's been a long
haul yeah but we got it there
we've got it where we needed richard
what are your thoughts yeah yes it's a
it's
it's a good area as you as you touched
on you know the further away from the
center you get
yeah if you look at the investment in
blackpool certainly like the
two five-star hotels that bill they're
not in the center but put them right up
the south shore
and again you look at the hotels in
around this area like the cliffs the
imperial
which are the higher end hotels though
away from the centre
yeah so the advantage of service
accommodation somewhere like this it's
the illuminations
the trams gold you're two minutes or the
tram stop so it's perfect yeah well
honestly so so andrew you bought this
house for 185
yes 185 000 you're renting it out for
just over 3 000 in total a month and the
great thing about apartments is that
you've not got any birds no bills
so they will pay that they've all got
their own electric they pay all their
own bills
so i don't have to you know factor any
bills in but what's the
what's the return on investment work out
on this property as a whole
um about 36 percent that's incredible
yeah well that's the thing with
blackpool you buy you buy low
very high yes 36 and that factors in
maintenance voids yeah management yeah
and you're paying a quite a big
link takes quite a big chunk but it
definitely goes way beyond
any sort of you know managing agents do
you know where to get hold of that
i used to run out in agency yeah and the
most annoying question
you get is what do you actually do for
your percent it's like
really yeah what do you you know people
investors sometimes can get greedy but
it's the best
every single time i spoke to one of my
winners wednesdays my students said
what's the key to your success every
single time
management management management so how
do you guys justify your your big 15
that's what it is right yeah how do you
justify that
so we uh do very much a boutique service
so
and it's very different in terms of we
do meet the clients the type of clients
that we do we do research into them now
yes you can do it through an agency and
you can send off
a full uniform and send off degrees we
actually go
to where they currently live in so
actually we're taking on
another investor as such so we
we do understand where they've come from
what one of the main reasons for going
looking at
where we currently live is the old
saying is you don't know somebody until
you've lived with them
so you go and see how they look at the
keep the current property yeah yeah it
gives you an
idea of how they're going to look after
them
and it's not just that it's right the
way through
to the letting and then managing that
one
you clean the rent we do the regulation
if the rent is like you chase the rent
yes we do
you don't send a break you work a
breakdown out and send that every single
month to the landlord yes
hands off landlord doesn't have to visit
no i
the other thing that's really good is um
what lee organizes is whatever
is organized i get all the receipts of
what's been spent on paint
it's all transparent um so everything i
know
and that you know it just makes it so
much
nicer that you know everything that's
going on yeah whereas i think with an
agent sort of in the high street you can
pick up you're not going to get all
those details
yeah so everything's broken down and it
just makes it so much
nicer to work with so this is the first
time i've been here today since it's all
been done so obviously lisa got a new
kitchen
and he's doing a fabulous job that's on
a good job
and you know what honestly i would live
here
yeah it's great so you've got into what
is the integrated
things that we're going in there there
you go that's why
yeah so yeah it's great french i don't
even know where the things are because i
haven't been there what did you think
when you first saw this kitchen when you
came today
um no i was really pleased with it
because it was just so grim in here
what did it look like before um well it
was crowded with um
lots of someone's belongings to the
ceiling
there was just loads of rubbish in here
it was a small galley kitchen
so they took the wall out just to open
it all up and it looks a lot brighter it
looks fantastic you guys
have a cracking job all right show me
what's next so that there was all new
electives
has it been rewarded is it going to be
wired it's been rewired in the bathroom
because there was a shower here and it
just it you know the layout wasn't great
what's the crap with this bathroom
because this doesn't look finished like
what's happening today
well what is um what's uh it's boiling
right so there was a bit of a delay
because of obviously the coronavirus
yeah we were meant to be having a boiler
put in well this would just be
a big boiler here no no no it wasn't no
it wasn't going to be
um no there was going to be a central
heating system put in
but then there was a delay um because of
the coronavirus they couldn't come in
and did it so they were waiting for that
to be put in
so now we've got now put electric shower
in because there's just been a backlog
of getting a new gas system put in and
stuff like that so finding solutions no
problems yeah so
you can't get the uh you can't get the
boiler and everything all in then you go
electric
so it's a good size two bedrooms yeah
i can't believe how big this one
apartment is yeah
this is the biggest no the the flat two
is bigger isn't it
so they're all quite big there's a
couple of um studios on the top floor
um and then there's a one bedroom flat
that michelle's in is that right that's
one bedroom
um and yeah as i say they're all fully
talented
it's great and it's you know what i've
noticed as well you remind me of me a
lot because
when you got to look at properties
you're asking lee's stuff because you
don't really know
because it's so hands-off yeah this is
the first time you've seen this house in
how long
um i haven't been here when was it
january you don't even remember
oh before christmas yeah it was just it
was about december the beginning of
december
yeah so since i've seen it since
december though of all these problems
it's all been rented out um they were
already rented
so no most of them were rented there's a
nursing since and then that other guy is
at jason
um so yeah two new tenants have moved in
since i've owned it um because two were
empty when i bought it
um so they've since moved in so they're
all full now so you know what i'm saying
is since you bought it
yeah it's been giving you an income yeah
yeah because i won
yeah so you bought this it's been giving
you an income ever since yeah you've not
been out
how many times have you seen it before
you bought it um only once
so you viewed it once you bought it yeah
had a good team
he's been giving you an income ever
since yeah and how much have you been
making then since you bought it
which has been renting out for
approximately um how much a month oh
yeah well it's been obviously um
it's just all the different rents come
in i can't remember off the top of my
head but
the total amount once this one's rented
will be
3085 yeah a month
yeah coming in once this time moves in
yeah the carpets are going in
this week so it's just sort of been
painted such as the carpets
yeah so what how did you find this
property then where
did you find it right yeah it was just
on the right move but i came down
um initially i stayed with lee because
he's got lots of
airbnbs in the area and that's how i met
him um
and then um yeah i viewed a few
properties and then the yield on this
was so
high um that i just liked it
so this probably you bought it for one
out of five yeah what was it on the
market for
it was on for 200 i think it originally
been on for 210 but then it'd been
reduced down to 200.
yeah um and then i bought it for 185.
and how much did the owner the current
owner how much did they buy for
they bought it for 210 in 2011.
wow yeah that's the thing so they bought
it from 210 2011
yeah and then almost 10 years later nine
years later you come and pick it up for
185
yeah which means that i don't know what
do you think that means
well it was crazy because in 2011 also
they all the other flats obviously you
can't see them because they're tentative
at the moment there was all new kitchens
put in
that whole building was rewired um
and everything was kind of done um it
was only this one that was a bit of
a mess um so it was a really good price
because then obviously the previous
owners had spent money on it putting all
the new kitchens in and the other
other flats yeah um so yeah it was a
really good price
a lot of people andrea would see this
property and they'd say
buy it for 185 rent it for 3 000
odd seven flats in blackpool yeah
36 return on investment after all costs
yeah sounds too good to be true it
sounds it sounds you know something's
bound to go wrong you don't have
terrible tenants yeah there's gonna be
tacklers and problems what would you say
what would you say
the thing is there's always gonna be
issues it's like having a bad day at
work you know we did have
an issue with one of the tenants because
there was a bit of a mess up with the
universal credit
um because we used to have it rented
well before i bought it it was with
another agent
and then the rents got paid directly to
them and then there was a bit of a mix
up so there was a bit of an issue there
but that's been sorted out now so that's
all up and running and
fine um so yeah you are always gonna
have
issues here and there but i think now
it's it's
you know over the worst of it and it's
you know once all moves in here it's all
up and running
the tenants in these other flats they're
lovely tenants they've done the garden
all the front garden they've planted
flowers they're really nice
um and i'm in touch with them so yeah
it's worked out really well
and you've been getting a recurring
income from this problem yeah since
day one yeah so you bought it day one
you're getting an idea
straight away yeah because there was
four when i bought it there was four
tenants that was already
living in their
and then upstairs is a one bed i think
she pays
i think it's 400 and then the other one
is the studio i think they pay 90 but it
was just comes in in different amounts
so on average you're talking about 450
500 each yeah
and if you've got fours it's a couple
thousand pounds yeah the mortgage
payments
how much four nine seven a month four
nine seven
yeah you've got no bells no council tax
no and now you're renting out the other
apartments
yeah this is the last one to go yeah and
you've got a tenant moving in
next week yeah so
it
well that's what you taught me and
that's the thing it's like i don't think
before i went to your crash course to be
quite honest
i wouldn't have had the confidence to
buy
something like this it's quite a big
deal it's quite a big house
and there's a lot to it and i wouldn't
have had the confidence i don't need to
buy it before i
encounter your question and you've
noticed in the crash course you've done
the crash course you've got
[Music]
or even bought up north without going to
a crash i wouldn't
how many properties do you own now seven
and that's a combination of hmos
yeah single let's you've also done some
vrrs
reverb development properties so this is
a cracker
yeah i'm just kind of one to ten how
would you rate it this one
um it's getting there i would say it's a
nine i think once it's finished
and then it's up and running at the
moment it's just obviously been you know
it's costing money
to do the bits and pieces but it's you
know
it's getting there so but then you need
to spend
you know you need to spend to accumulate
and that's how it works you must
be very proud of yourself yeah i am
pleased with it i
honestly it was such a state in here
before it was literally the whole
ceiling was
piled full of furniture and uh
did you remember the whole the whole all
the walls everything they were like
thick um what they call it like cream
cheesy
type of plaster
[Music]
pounds yeah does that cover removing all
of the furniture yeah he did it all
yeah and he put in the kitchen for free
because i helped him
get a deal um with
chris on a rent to buy scheme so he did
this as a way of saying thank you so i
didn't pay for the kitchen
that's nice so he did that that's the
thing it's all about
relationships yeah well you've done an
absolutely amazing job
and lee honestly pleasure pleasure to
see what you're doing
thank you so we're off where are we off
to now lane ends
what am i going to think of that you'll
love it will i yes i love it
i'm excited let's go let's go check it
out
hello
thank you
nice it's a bit different from black
ball it's been a bit of a work in
progress
but have you got this extension yeah so
it was originally like this and then we
had the extension we wanted to go out
further but because um
of the land they wouldn't allow us to go
any more so yeah it is what it is
but yeah we made the best of what it is
so this is um
about standing natural beauty okay
oh wow so um so yeah the garden's not
finished yet the guy was left some few
weeks ago he keeps letting me down
so that's a work in progress as well but
hopefully this weekend he's going to
come sort of out
right the area is just nice yeah well
it's really good because it's like
literally about two and a half miles
from marlow
yeah and there's a lot of people because
marlo's so expensive
people can't afford to live there so
this is kind and there's not many hmos
in this area
have you have you got any have you
started advertising in the rooms yet
yeah the ad went out last thursday
there's some people coming the weekend
to have a look um because some people
are working away but moving into the
area
yeah so then you'll rent it out nicely
hopefully come and have a look
so this was originally the lounge so we
split so
nice right so we split the you know
obviously the lounge
yeah to make this as a bedroom right so
this is the kitchen oh
wow so what we did is we just put up
this wall
to make it cut and there was a wall up
here so we took the wall out just to
make
it through sort of open area yeah and
then we had this back extension put in
because there needs to be like an old
conservatory that has fallen down
so they just put in this kind of extra
area
for this and then what we did is
initially on the
original plans they were going to put
this bedroom through the middle of the
kitchen
and when i came i said to the builder i
don't know why the architect did that
but it just wasn't going to work
so we put a bedroom down here whoever
gets this room
is quite sort of out the way yeah of
you know rather than being in the middle
of the kitchen it's quite
sort of secluded and yeah
it's done really high standard how much
did you buy this place for
260. so houses along here
without without obviously being having
an extension they sell for about 3.25
we got it for 260 because it was um
sold back through the council because
the people who lived here before
were like an elderly couple and they'd
gone into well one had died and one had
gone into a home
and they couldn't they had no family so
they can
cope well they have you know she had
dementia so she obviously couldn't cope
with it
so it was sold as a quick sale and so we
bought it cash um
there was quite a lot of people looking
you know when we came for the open day
here there was about 30 people in the
house
um wanting to buy it because it was such
a cheap house because as i said other
houses around here sell for about 325.
3.25
so we got it for that price we spent
about 106
000 on the extension and the whole
refurb
and the new value um the agent said
between
450 and 460. very nice so
so it's you know it's been good now
we're going to pull our money out
at least sort of 200 000 and
um and then go again with something else
how much are you marketing these rooms
so
the ones with the ensuites will be 6.50
a month
there's one room upstairs because we
didn't get the license for the seven bed
we've done it as a kind of a little
living area
so my hmo managers managed um
put that up for 7.95 so they get kind of
two rooms
and then the ones without the bathroom
so there's one there's two rooms that
will share the bathroom
they will go for sort of 5.50 so i think
the kind of
the overall monthly figure will be about
3845 for them and that's realistic for
the area yeah
i think considering it's very close to
london yeah
it's probably what half an hour on the
train yeah so you could yeah
from yeah high wickham about 35 minutes
yeah yeah it's great so this is the
bathroom that these two
rooms will share so these are the only
two that's a shared bathroom
yeah so that's in there and then so this
is the extension
of that it's not the biggest room in the
world but it's
you know it's got everything in it i
think you get
without sounding rude or snobby
i think you get a better level of tenant
um
then sort of up north but why is that
because obviously the people up north
are really good a lot more summer yeah
some are
not yeah i just feel like i just feel
like these rooms
these rooms i'm just so confident
they're going to run fast they're going
to be good quality tenants
yeah and i mean oh i feel i know your
um return on investment in blackpool is
amazing that we've just recently seen
yeah
but i if if i had to choose which
properties to go for
it'll be this one yeah yeah well it is
easier obviously it's because it's i'm
live 20 minutes away from here so it's
easier to although i'm going to have a
hmo manager
manager if there are any problems i need
to pop down
it's up the road so it's easier um
but but you won't have to do that
because this this might have problems
with a good management company this will
just be
yeah and and lynn who manages it in this
area she's got like
over 200 houses she manages and she's
absolutely brilliant
yeah um and uh she's really on the ball
with stuff
so um she manages one of my other hmos
in wickham
and um yeah and it's been really good so
far has it yeah
it's really good rents as well what kind
of occupancy
does she have across her room um
literally i think every time i speak to
her she has like two rooms empty
that out of the 200 she have like two
empty i think it's gone down i think the
last time i spoke to her
i think there's now seven rooms empty
out of the whole
portfolio of houses that she manages
because obviously some people have
you know been made redundant they've
gone home
we had two pilots in our other house
training pilots
and obviously because of corona they
went back home because their course
you know was finished or not finished
but on hold
um so two of the rooms are empty at my
other one at the moment but
um hopefully they'll be filled again
soon so when you refinance this
yeah are you expecting to pull out all
of your money uh no
because i think um because i we bought
this with
another investors money yeah um i just
want to pull out what i've put in
and another 100 that we're going to use
to do another joint venture again so
so you finance this for someone else's
money yeah wow
very good so that that's that's the plan
did you put any of your own money into
this deal
yeah so why i paid for the the refurb
and the extension
so my own money was about yeah about
1600 where did you get that money from
so that was from the sale of our house
yeah because you said rent you ha rent
where you live
yeah so we sold our house and used some
of the money yeah
but the interesting thing is though with
the money that you make from this
and the other properties yeah the house
that you're now renting
yeah it's quite a lot nicer than the
house yeah it's a lot nicer yeah it's
like a lovely farmhouse really nice road
surrounded by
sheeps and fields that's a lot nicer
where we live now
what would you say the advantages are
because a lot of people don't take on my
advice on that a lot of people
they've got their own home they're in it
outright and they go no no i've worked
all my life for this house now i want to
build upon that
but as i say just sell that and invest
it smart which was what you've done
yeah what would you say the advantages
to selling your house and renting and
then investing that money
well i think the advantage is i can't
speak for other people but the
advantages for us
has been that we're living in a lot
nicer house than
what we were living we're living on a
very busy main road before
um it's a lot bigger house um obviously
if
something goes wrong in the house we can
call up the landlord so we don't have to
we don't worry yeah because it's part of
being attacked yeah
and what else is there obviously it's
freed up money
to in enhance our monthly
income yeah um so that's
it's had a lot of advantages smart um
yeah
and um i think the last time we spoke um
as we bought the house um what i spoke
about on my
last video actually the money that i put
into that i pulled out and put to this
so it's already been recycled
so so yeah it's just kind of ticking
over
and the fact that you've got a great
you've done a great extension on it you
can push the value off i've got sensor
lights in the hallway which i learned
from my last hmo because every time i go
there the lights are always on in the
hallway
so they're all on sensors yeah good so
this this
these are the rooms that is going to be
for one person or potentially a couple
because we didn't get the license for
the seven bed and i wanted to keep the
room
downstairs as a bedroom rather than
another living area because there's
enough living space
we're just going to rent this whole area
to one person so they've got their own
bathroom which is a
you know really nice size so violence
you know and i'm renting this dent so i
want to pay
seven nine so you'll get this room as
well big bright
yeah bedroom yeah great and looks like
it's near the bed which is yeah
lovely bathroom i love the colors the
yellow and the green the plants yeah
gives it life and then they've just got
like this little office space here
there was so much uproar with all the
neighbours i think it just
the hmo um department said
have it run as a six bed first and
providing it's run
well yeah then we should at a later date
be able to get the license but
i'm to be honest this is quite a small
room
and i'm happy just to rent this as well
yeah because the thing is if you rented
that out on its own
bathroom yeah you'd probably only get
six six hundred yeah
instead of seven nine five she lost two
hundred quid yeah are you gonna rent
this out for about five
so you'd make a bit more money well
you'd probably get maybe
about with yeah because they would have
to then share that bathroom
so you're probably talking sort of 500
550 so it's quite a small room so you're
actually going to lose a couple hundred
pounds yeah and you're gonna have the
hassle of an extra tenant you're gonna
have the expense you can have the hassle
of having to get
surely you need planning permission to
get a seven
yeah you do which i've applied for right
um but i've been told
although on the council website it's
still pending i've
been told by my architect that they're i
think they're gonna turn it down
so then i just thought plan b let's just
go with this little
living area yes and once you've
refinanced it
yeah and pulled out not all of the money
all of your money yeah what what kind of
mortgage payments are you interested
only um
so on a 200 000 mortgage
um see i've got another property and i
think
the mortgage on that is 240 and at the
moment i'm paying like 438 a month
and that's on 2 40 so i'm not sure what
it will be at the moment obviously
interest rates have dropped
yeah um maybe around about 3 15. yeah
um what what is the rentman on the whole
house because you're gonna make good
profit
so so the rent on the whole house would
be about 3845
yeah and then obviously taking off
depending on what the mortgage payments
you're still looking at stuff like 3400
yeah after the insurance is inside and
after all the management
and then bills so the the bills
at my other property with the management
and bills
in total is about another 500 a month
right so
so about three thousand so i'll be about
three thousand it's incredible though
yeah that's that's a salary yeah and
then to obviously take out
some of the money to do it again yeah
it's absolutely brilliant
yeah because she's getting three
thousand pound income yeah from from
this one house but then you've got your
money to go
and do it again do it again so you'll be
on property number eight soon
yeah well we've been looking have you
yeah for my sins but i don't know i'll
put an offering on that one in blackpool
but i'm still waiting to hear i think
there's been a lot of uh interest in it
yeah and you're kind of putting me off
it a bit no
all right
all right all i was saying is all i was
saying to andrew is
blackpool is not it's not a bad
investment area nothing against
blackball
and the property that i'm just showing
that she's bought is amazing
and it's got great tenants already in
there great
but what my advice was number one
i would personally want to see how it
goes for six twelve months with the
tenants in blackpool before you suddenly
go and buy
another live apartment no no it's like
well hold on a minute
let's just see how it goes a little bit
before pushing jumping the gun
secondly is i i don't think you should
be buying
lots and lots of houses i think every
time you make an investment you should
be going bigger
and bigger and bigger because a small
deal
is more headache than a big deal and you
don't want those are small deals
well that's why i've got fur the the one
in blackpool the one we were looking at
is you know one house with five flats in
rather than you know you've got say you
were to buy a load of
50 000 pound houses you've got
you know lots of people but the thing is
if the tenant although it's one house
yeah you've still got five tenants yeah
and the more tenants you have we've
found this haven't we yeah the more
problems you have
yeah even if even if you've got the
managed yeah
tenants cause problems yeah so what i
would advise
is to move on to stuff i mean unless you
could rent out the whole block to the
council
yeah and do it on social housing yeah
but i'd just be saying let's think
systems now
especially with your health and things
i'll be thinking i don't want
how much hassle is it when you've got
loads of tenants
mandy oversees our managers
here's everything you've got a really
good management company yeah but if lee
packed up and leave by the way it's
amazing
we've had amazing property managers that
are thinking like oh we're actually
meeting other things
or oh which like you can't rely on
one person so no you can't and and trust
me
if you get a few bad tenants or if they
stop paying rent and then legos are
actually i've changed
and you're like well i ain't got the
energy done it could be a plank on it
yeah and then you end up going oh and
then you just sell it
yeah bring something bigger and better
so what i'm saying to you is
maybe think about what is just bigger
and better right now um
yeah yeah guys put me off the other
channel no
yeah i wouldn't advise that if you
hadn't already bought in blackpool yeah
if you hadn't got already got seven
properties if you weren't already but
from your perfect perspective now you're
not trying to explain
i'm just trying to i'm just trying to i
think my plan is
while i'm still around is to
maximize the income but yeah you're
right with as
less hassle as possible so what i would
do is i'd be like right i'd either buy a
commercial
property because commercial is easy but
the problem with commercial is because
we're in a recession
it's good time to buy commercial but
rentability yeah i just worry about that
yeah
i've got a friend in um
like locally but he's got a development
in birmingham
and he's got a large shop and the
the rate the rates of the the the
building downstairs is so high it's
almost like eating up a lot of these
profits for the flat it depends on the
it depends on what it is yeah if you've
got a warehouse that you rent to amazon
yeah you're gonna be all right yeah but
then of course their entry costs to that
are high yeah you're probably talking
about
four percent yield on that which is
obviously
really large but the reason it's low is
because it's pretty guaranteed the
higher return and the higher
yield you get the more risk and the more
problems so if you go
oh you know i've bought a property in
blackpool that's giving me 30 or
whatever
that's great but because it's such a
high roi it's probably going to be
have more risks yeah whereas if you go
actually i've got something that's
15 but it's guaranteed
yeah totally systemized 20-year lease
is gonna be less return but it's totally
risk-free yeah
um but you're at stage now you might be
thinking this is not what you're saying
i i think ideally like you know what i
would like but i think in this current
climate it's very risky
is to do like a flip yeah or something
but at the moment
because things are all a bit up in the
air
you know you could end up doing going
through all the work and you know
buying a house cheap doing an extension
adding value
and then you've gone through all that
work prices drop
and you're expecting to make x amount
and then it's like oh
you know you've done all that work so
that's at the moment that's
to me a little bit risky i just love the
way you've done it
did you choose all this yeah to be
honest a lot of it was
um when we dressed the last hmo a lot of
it was from there
so i kept a lot of it and i've just
redressed this and then i'll move on to
the next one
so when they move in they just get
they're all brand new beds they
all just get a mattress protector and
all the quilts and
things all get taken out yeah and then
it gets moved on to the next one
this is the last two rooms all right
very nice
yeah it's i can i can imagine um i can
imagine someone living here
who's a 36 year old doctor
yeah well i'm sure 36 year old doctors
probably could have enough money for
their own house
no but you'd be surprised yeah you'd be
really surprised yeah to be fair
in my other hmo i've got a police
officer there was two trainee pilots
someone who worked in film and
um who else was there oh a teacher
an astronaut but that's it
people think people think hmos oh you
know scotty working no
like professional people when you get
them nice so
i love this house yes i really i'm so
glad that we came to this yeah
um yeah it's very different from the
blackpool one because i've done it from
the beginning
you know i've had i've had control
um you know despite my health issues and
and being in hospital trying to speak to
builders as i've just had a brain tumor
removed you know i'm trying to deal with
stuff i don't know how you've
uh well it was it was quite difficult
you know but
i just you know i passed while i was in
hospital i passed a few things on to
megan because
you know she was kind of paying
tradesmen and stuff because i just
couldn't even
you know do online banking literally i
was like
my brain was like much yeah as you can
imagine but also the brain tumor
um that you told us literally i think a
week or so before you say oh i'm going
to have a brain gym removed next week
and i was thinking
what yeah yeah well no it was an
emergency
it was actually emergency that i went in
for that because i was going to have the
radiotherapy but then i
just like was really ill and then they
just i was rushed into hospital and they
did it
what um like i don't know how many of my
viewers
might have health issues um
certainly not on the severity that
you've had but
if you were speaking to somebody that
did have health issues health scares
whatever it might be um but also wanted
to do
property like what advice would you give
them i i think
you know having the whole cancer thing
and
when i went to your crash course and
then got diagnosed
um i think like literally two months
later when i first
initially went i think i went into
september got diagnosed in december it
just really spared me on
to think you know how how long am i
going to be around for i really need to
just do something now and it just
really gave me the kick that i needed to
to do this because i just wanted to
build up the business to leave
you know things you know financially
stable
for the family when i'm gone
that sounds hard but that is the reality
it is the reality and you know
spencer's now starting to take an
interest because he's
obviously aware of the situation and you
know we've talked a lot about you know
what's going to happen after and stuff
and um and he's you know and that's why
i think now he's
stepped up and he's you know speaking to
builders and making sure things are done
and
taking more control of things which is a
really good thing because
i'm not always going to be able to do it
yeah
what what are the doctors saying about
your uh future like what
well it's they said it's now incurable
so i don't know how long
you know i'm on chemo at the moment so i
don't know how long
that's going to work for um they found
more cancer in my lymph nodes
um obviously the brain tumor has been
removed but
there's a high chance that you can start
getting
you know regrowth there um
fingers crossed it's okay at the moment
and so i'm having like three monthly
scans
um but you know it's incurable i'm not
gonna make old bones
so it is what it is but i've learned to
just accept it and just make the most
of you know feeling well and
doing what i can while i can and you
generally feel well
yeah i do at the moment i do i have days
where i'm really really tired and i'm
just
in bed and feeling absolutely shattered
and everything's a bit of an effort but
then i have days where i feel like today
i feel okay
um but then i'll have you know like last
weekend i was in bed
you know after i saw you last week i was
literally in bed all weekend
um and i wasn't very well over the
weekend
but then monday i got up and uh you know
what i felt fine
yeah what can we do for you to help
support you over the next
you know a few months years or whatever
like how can we well
i think you have been a big help already
so i mean i really do you've really
inspired me to do what i'm doing
um and i'm really grateful for that
i really am i really am i feel like it's
a huge moment
i
but without your support and your
youtube videos
and your energy like even when i was in
hospital i was i just thought oh my god
i feel really awful and i literally just
got one of your videos and your voice
and your energy
just lifted my spirits because of the
way that you are
no seriously oh that means a lot
and you really have i just want to
publicly say
massive respect i am in awe of your
property investment skills
i mean honestly with all that you've
been through the fact that you've
managed to do all this kind of
development
extensions projects all over the country
high five high five has been a good ride
it has been good yeah
awesome ups and downs but mostly ups
yeah hopefully she didn't look convinced
but guys if you want to learn more about
property investment
then you need to subscribe to the
channel and you can subscribe
whereabouts on the screen is it
it's usually up there yeah it is it's
right there if you want to watch
andrea's full interview you can check
that out right here although a lot's
happened since then
and i look forward to seeing you on the
next video thanks see you later see you
later